as we covered late in 2017 Minnesota
Democratic senator Al Franken has
resigned effective yesterday after
allegations of sexual impropriety former
Republican congresswoman from Minnesota
and all a lap around religious lunatic
Michele Bachmann is now asking God
whether she should run for that seat
vacated by Al Franken I wonder what God
would have to say about it here she is
on the equally Looney Tunes Jim Baker
show and you're going to notice along
the bottom of the screen while she's
talking that sales of bulk quantity food
is taking place a common staple of this
program of Jim Baker's let's listen to
the former congresswoman Michele
Bachmann here now in Minnesota Al
Franken as you know as resign I'm from
Minnesota I've had people contact me and
urge me to run for the Senate seat the
only reason I would run is for the
ability to take these principles into
the United States Senate and to be able
to advocate for these principles yeah
the question is is it should it be me
should it be now but there's also cause
there's a price you pay sure it's and
the price is bigger than ever because it
is mop is so toxic it is never been and
my husband and I aren't money people oh
yeah that's the thing we're not we're
normal right normal people were not
money people if you're a billionaire you
can maybe defend yourself
yeah we're not money people and so you
know you can have you can have frivolous
lawsuits filed against you all the time
and then what do you do I mean it is it
is really tough if you're going against
the tide in DC if you're trying to stand
for biblical principles in DC and you
stick your head up out of the hole you
do you know the blades come whirring and
they try to chop you off yeah you might
have noticed that 1496 servings of some
kind of food were available for 650
bucks at the bottom of the screen and
you could get nearly three thousand
servings for just $1,200 so a little bit
of a discount offered there if you
wanted that that is quite a deal though
it's actually a pretty good deal yeah of
what the food is I have absolutely no
clue as far as Michele Bachmann not
being a money person well her net worth
is somewhere around three million
dollars right the the median American
worth for someone her age including
equity in one's home is about a hundred
and forty four thousand dollars so she's
not a money person because she has a net
worth of only 20 times the American
median for people her age all right
interesting perspective and here she is
unsure if she is being called to run by
God for Al Franken Senate seat people
took the position that that Obamacare is
bad and so that moved the debate I think
I was wildly successful I didn't win
when I left the contest because I felt
like you know I fulfilled the calling
that God gave me so the question is am I
being called to do this now I don't know
is God calling her to run for this seat
the most inaccurate comment in the
entire video is when she says that she
and her husband are normal anyone who's
seen five minutes of footage of either
of them knows that that could not be
further from the truth has God ever
given michelle bachman good advice in
fact i'd like to know what other advice
God has given her at least she thinks
God has given her iight rule II believe
that Michele Bachmann would be more
suited to a psychiatric facility than to
the White House or to a Senate seat
yeah and whenever these politicians ask
God if they should run or not for a
particular office yeah it seems like God
always says yes oh yeah you're the one
to do it and I think they do that so
they don't come across as selfish or
self-interested right it was a calling
from high above and then when they lose
it was all part of God's plan as well so
it completely absolves them of any
responsibility or maybe just blame
because they were bad candidates now as
far as Michele Bachmann's chances for
winning this seat I would not write off
her chances to win there have been many
Republican senators from Minnesota
historically it's been about 17 years
since the last one but okay and the
types of people that Michele Bachmann
would activate are exactly the types of
people that vote for so-called morality
reasons or because they're on a crusade
for God or whatever they might actually
get out to vote in the typically low
turnout midterms for her it might be an
interesting race Michele Bachmann versus
keith Ellison maybe maybe just her will
get involved
is that actually right yeah well he was
governor of Minnesota years ago that
would be interesting but in any case I
would not write this off as just some
lunatic
running for the Senate with no chance to
win this is some lunatic running for the
Senate possibly with a chance to win and
that's a much scarier thing the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad